[Music]
you know I need to tweet this out
because I'll stir up some people this
younger generation that is so
technologically savvy if I don't know
how to work my iPhone I can hand it to
one of you in your 20s and you can fix
it in a heartbeat
you're so technologically savvy and when
it comes to understanding human nature
you're just stupid because the number of
you on the internet that believe
everything you read on the Internet
that's just absolutely stupid I have a
keyboard I can type up whatever I want
to type up and put it on the internet
and you'll believe it and so you
automatically assume when you read
something that it's true on the Internet
Abe Lincoln said everything on the
internet was true I mean you know and
they believed it
hello Abe Lincoln was not okay it's so
basic
is that's the ultimate sarcasm right
there but I mean it's nuts because this
on the internet doesn't make it true and
because you put out your opinion on the
internet doesn't make it true about what
someone else purchased because you don't
know what you're talking about you
should maybe mind your own freaking
business so that kind of comes into the
same equation comes into the same
discussion your friend buys a car and
you're like got an opinion about it but
maybe you ought to just have an opinion
about your own self because you pretty
much suck right now and you got a lot of
work to do on you instead of figuring
out what's wrong with your friend and
putting that on your little Facebook
Instagram account
jeez man and then everybody thinks it's
true just because you had an opinion
people believe anything that's printed
on the internet it's just ridiculous
just automatically assume that it's true
that's just dumb this is the Dave Ramsey
show